Is there a test for cancer, a family member suspects breast cancer that doesn't involve a biopsy, so I assume this person doesn't want to do a biopsy, they suspect breast cancer.
We get the only way to get a legal diagnosis of cancers to do a biopsy.
So, you can't get a legal diagnosis cancer without doing a biopsy.
Even a radiologist who maybe does a scan of somebody and, you know, radiology, you learn how to identify pathology.
So, you can look at a radiograph, whether it be an X, or a CT, or MRI, and you could go, oh, wow, that's osteosarcova.
Oh, wow, that's, you know, pneumonia, or that's this.
Technically, a radiologist can't write that, they can say, it's suspected of this, so they use terminology like just that it's possibly this.
They can't diagnose, especially cancer, you can't diagnose for the biopsy, so they can make suggestive comments, but that's all they can do.
Even, you know, with ultrasound, same thing with a mammogram, same thing, so we're talking about for breast cancer itself.
Well, it would be the thing that would be done if you went into your oncologist and said, I have a lump in my breast, could you check this out?
Well, the first thing they would do is a mammogram, and then after a mammogram, they may do it ultrasound, and they may do it ultrasound guided biopsy, and then from that, they'll make decisions of care.
Because that's what will, those are the steps that are going to lead to a cancer diagnosis.
Now, I understand there's a lot of people go, hey, I'm not going down that pathway at all. I ain't going in there, and I just don't want to do that. Well, that's that person's choice.
And, but we can't diagnose cancer without that. Now, you can get some pretty good ideas. There's some tests that you could do to get some ideas.
Now, if it's female, you do the female tumor panel, tumor marker panel, male, a male tumor marker panel, if you suspect a cancer.
Now, certainly if male has elevated PSA of any considerable value, you know, it's a pretty good indication that there's something going on.
And, you know, typically, but I prostatic hypertrophy doesn't result in a elevated PSA.
Now, typically, if a person doesn't have cancer, they typically will not show elevated tumor markers of any kind.
But the problem is is that two workers are specific to cancer except PSA to prostate.
And a person can have, you know, very advanced cancer and not show positive any positive tumor markers.
So two workers is not diagnostic of anything. So even with the person with advanced prostate cancer goes in and doesn't PSA and it's let's say it's 250.
Wow, you know, this is fairly advanced prostate cancer. Still, they can't diagnose it as cancer.
You know, your GP may say it, but from a legal standpoint, get diagnosed until it's biopsy and they won't do any treatment, but don't get into biopsy too.
So if you want to follow through with any standards of care treatment, then you have to go down, you know, their pathway and get biopsy.
If the, you know, if you're saying and asking this question that they don't want to follow through with any treatment, well, you don't have to get biopsy. You can do other things like this.
There are what are called ominous sides on a, a complete amount of all panel as well.
If the person has low protein levels, if they, if they're cholesterol levels plummet, let's say they had it, you know, their cholesterol was always in the one IDs that they went in and got there.
You know, physical and their, and their total protein value is low and album is low, globular in this low and their cholesterol wasn't say 125.
They'd go, oh, wow, I'm really doing good. No, that's an ominous sign for cancer.
So, but again, it doesn't tell you that you do have cancer, you have to follow up that tells you an ominous sign tells you to start digging further.
That's asking the question a lot. Now, the person, you know, suspects cancer because of other things you, you know, should definitely do, you know, general blood work up like a CDC.
Make sure that they don't have anemia and you're dealing with that bite into cause of that.
And you're complete metabolic panel as well, but two of our panels are another thing that you could use to screen.